hello very good morning to you and we
start with that breaking news as the
energy regulator ofgem announces the new
price cap for fuel bills in england
wales and scotland so from october the
energy price cap will increase to 35
pounds and that's a huge rise from the
current
1971 pounds per year that's been in
force since april well let's get
reaction straight away from our business
correspondent helen and smith who's
embarking in east london so helen ann
smith a huge rise in the price cap 3549
pounds
hitting people's bills from october just
as was feared
yeah that's exactly right anna it's a
hugely important morning very
significant and i think very frightening
for a lot of people up and down this
country who have been knowing that this
price cap is coming this price cap rise
has been coming knowing that autumn is
on its way and feeling very worried
indeed about how they're going to pay
their bills through the coming winter so
we know now just how much that cap is
going to go up by
3549 pounds a year will be the typical
uh price of an average person's bill
that is the cap that off gems say the
maximum that they can charge just to
sort of clarify what that cap involves
uh it is a cap on essentially the unit
of energy that each of us will buy that
off gem say that the energy companies
are allowed to sell plus the standing
charge so essentially it is the maximum
amount that a typical bill uh is allowed
to cost essentially just important to
stress though your bills could be
slightly more than that or slightly less
than that depending on how much energy
you use it's also the price for what's
called a default tariff or a standard
variable tariff as that's the sort of
tariff that you're on worth saying that
people on pre-payment meters will also
have a rise to their cap as well it will
be slightly different to this number
that we're talking about and once we get
that full release from off gen we'll go
through those numbers and we'll bring
them um to you as well but look i think
it's important to take a step back and
put this number in some context this is
in roughly the region of 80 percent in
terms of the amount that bills are
rising from what they currently are now
they're currently
just shy of 2 000 pounds a year rising
by roughly 80 percent so that is a
hugely significant rise and compare that
to last winter because remember the
price of the bills now came into force
in april so last time last october the
cap that was in force throughout last
winter i mean we're talking about now
two and a half times as much this winter
roughly uh and so a huge huge difference
for people in their lives in a very
frightening time indeed the causes and
the reasons we've covered them a lot
anna but i think it's worth just
reiterating uh the big driver in all
this is the massive surge in the price
of wholesale gas
those prices of wholesale gas were
rising before the russian invasion of
ukraine but that is the big factor uh
that have caused them to absolutely
skyrocket to record highs in recent
months they really peaked back in the
spring when that invasion happened but
they have started really rising up again
to roughly what they were when the
invasion happened and the reason for
that is there's a a sense and a fear
that lots of companies across europe are
trying to hedge trying to gather in buy
as much energy they can ahead of the
winter but also a sense that russia is
flexing its muscles uh we know that next
week uh the pipeline the big pipeline
that's called nordstrom one it carries
russian gas to europe it's being shut
off for three days the russians say
that's because of maintenance but the
markets fear that it's a threat in terms
of how russia wants to behave in terms
of its selling of gas to europe it sells
some 40
of european gas in the eu comes from
russia it certainly did before the war
so a hugely significant supply and that
is what caused prices to skyrocket but
of course if you're a customer at home
that's not going to make you feel much
better
and that wholesale price unfortunately
your household energy company your
consumer-facing energy company people
that you buy your energy from
they are in a position where
they have to pay those exorbitant prices
to buy their gas they have to pass that
on to their customers or they risk
going out of business and then going out
of business would make the whole
situation worse so we are in this very
critical position the only option really
for people is for the government to do
more to try and mitigate some of that
impact of these huge huge rising bills
both candidates have indicated very
strongly that they will do something
what that is remains to be seen and of
course many people say it might all come
in quite late it takes a long time to
implement these sort of measures so
nerve-wracking news indeed today the
energy price cap up in a region of about
80
3549 pounds a year for the typical bill